So we can go pretty far back in time
with the maternal and paternal lines. But we can go
even further back with the cool feature that allows
us to look at how much natal ancestry we have.
>> I'm sorry. I, are you saying that
humans and Neanderthals were interbreeding at some point?
>> Well, DNA from Neanderthal fossils is
indicating just that. It seems like it did
happen. And so, why don't we go and take a look. And see how much Neanderthal
ancestry you have, Matt?
>> Let's do it. So, here we are looking at the, y chromosome
[INAUDIBLE].
>> Okay.
>> How do I get to my Neanderthal results?
>> So, go up to my results. And then, it should have a
[INAUDIBLE].
>>
[INAUDIBLE]
Neanderthal ancestry.
>> That's it, yeah. And, hey.
>> Oh wow. So it says an estimated 2.7%of my DNA is.
>> Right. From Neanderthals.
>> That's right. Which is pretty cool. and we do, do that by comparing
your DNA to what's known for Neanderthals.
What the DNA that's been obtained from neanderthal
fossils and
>> So that means if you have DNA from Neanderthals that means you've
only been able to get that DNA 'because Neanderthals aren't alive any more.
>> That's right.
>> So the only way to get that is from fossils, then.
>> Absolutely. And, so, and, it's, it's been exciting
to get more and more DNA out of these
Neanderthal fossils. At first, it was only possible to
get mitochondrial DNA. and the mitochondrial DNA didn't know
that living humans have any sharing of mitochondrial DNA with
Neanderthals. So everyone was kind of concluding that there was no
inter-breeding. But now when we look at the rest of the
chromosomes, one to 22 we, start seeing evidence of the inter-breeding.
>> Wow, that's really cool. And, it looks down here that
I can actually see where all of my friends and family.
>> Yeah.
>> With Neanderthal ancestry.
>> I'm the average, but it looks.
>> That's right.
>> like you can be higher, like
>> Yes.
>> 3.1%.
>> Yeah, and your dad has a little more than you.
>> Yeah, let's see, yeah, my dad's like at 3%.
>> Yeah, I mean, these are
you know, just rough approximations, 'because it's hard
to get an exact estimate. Oh, but let
me tell you one important thing. As soon as I saw that most of your DNA trace
to Europe, I could have guessed roughly your
Neanderthals ancestors because Europeans typically have between 2 and
4% of their ancestors traced to Neanderthals. whereas
people who, most of their ancestry traces to Africa
have far less. Because Neanderthals were not
inter-breeding with, with our ancestors in, in Africa.
>> Well, and we can even see that, here I am at 2.7%.
>> Right.
>> And Roy King. And his father who have African history
[CROSSTALK]
>> Yes, 1.2% and 1.5%.
>> 1.5%.
>> Yes. So, so that makes a lot of sense on knowing what
we do about the timing and the
location of where this inter-breeding takes place.
>> Very cool.
>> Mm-hm. Great.